Nora, I am so honored to copilot today's edition
of Drew's News, where we serve the stories....
Sunny side up!
Thanks guys.
Okay, Nora, please kick us off.
Okay, on it.
All right, Time Magazine just announced
their kid of the year, this is new, cover,
and the honor goes to Gitanjali Rao
of Lone Tree, California.
She's 15, already invented a device
that can detect lead contamination in water,
coded an app that uses artificial intelligence
to flag cyberbullies and apparently
you can read all about it in Time Magazine.
She said, you just need to be passionate about one thing
and try and solve it.
And I was not doing anything near that cool
when I was 15, but were you?
I was, no, I was kind of a burner at 15,
but I, by 19, I started my own business, Flower Films,
so, you know, I wasn't saving the world,
but I was trying to make joy in it.
You were more precocious than the rest of us.
I was born with like a martini
and like, let's do this, you know?
I already feel 60 and 70 years old now,
but it's good to get a jumpstart,
but what she did is so profound
and Angelina Jolie did the interview,
which is really exciting to read.
Okay, in huge news for the movie business,
the place that I turned to
to have a very stable job and career,
the Wall Street Journal reports that Warner Brothers
will release all their 2021 movies in theaters,
but more importantly on HBO Max simultaneously.
They're kicking it off with
Wonder Woman 1984 on Christmas Day
and they've got 17 large ticket item movies,
Lin-Manuel Miranda's "In the Heights,"
the star studded Dune, Space Jam Two with LeBron
and Matrix 4, and the movies we'll spend a month on HBO Max,
and they'll be in theaters possibly,
I think it's going to be a let's see what happens
with COVID and movie openings.
But I think what this means is not only is this just
jaw dropping bombshell Hollywood news,
but I think it's now nice to know we can rest for 2021.
This is what will be happening because this whole
keep pushing movies thing and theaters and you know,
the business, it was just too crazy and too much.
They've made a decision.
This is gonna change the landscape for the year.
I do have hope for theaters, you know, in the future,
but I'm glad that they made
such a big bold call for right now.
You're so right. It's huge.
Our company Paramount Plus is doing
the same kind of thing in 2021.
But I have to say, I feel a little sad.
I missed the movie theaters. I'm sort of nostalgic about it.
I mean, where was the place you went
when you were 15 or 16 on your first date
when you had your first make-out?
The theaters were like the place to go.
So I do hope once everybody gets vaccinated,
they'll be back in business and strong.
Well and Paramount has CBS All Access to turn to.
They already have a successful platform.
So I'm interested to see what their move will be.
Okay, and finally, in shoe news,
the new Air Jordans actually just launched and they are
automatic lacing, as in you have an app on your phone
and they will do the lacing
for your preset satisfactory mode.
This is just so crazy.
Here we are, this is the future, it's very Marty McFly.
And in shoe news, we have one last headline for the road.
And it's one I'm really proud of
because we're teaming up with Payless
for a special give back this holiday.
They're gonna donate 6,000 pairs of shoes
and we'll roll into the clip.
But before we do Nora,
I just wanna say it has been an honor
and a realized dream of a lifetime to co-anchor some news.
And I would love to do this anytime, anywhere with you.
Thank you.
Oh my goodness. Well, thank you.
Love Drew's News.
(upbeat music)